here's a good question can you actually
grow your muscles when you're doing
intermittent fasting
and keto now i have done other videos on
this but i want to go more into the
exercise part of this because
if you're doing intermittent fasting and
keto
and you're not doing exercise you're not
going to grow your muscles
okay why because the most
important stimulus to muscle hypertrophy
which is growing muscle
is the intensity of the exercise
okay intensity of the exercise now
before i get into the exercise part i
want to talk about the
foundation that surrounds this because
when you do intermittent fasting
consistently and you're actually
adapted to ketosis you will have higher
levels of human growth hormone
and human growth hormone does
cause the growth of muscle and it also
prevents the loss of muscle
now on the opposite spectrum if you're
eating frequently through the day
and you have insulin resistance and you
have blood sugar issues
or you're pre-diabetic or diabetic
you're going to have
less amino acids going into that muscle
you're going to have more atrophy
so this is an important principle to
consume
two meals a day maybe even one meal a
day but
i think two meals a day would be perfect
maybe keep your carbs at the higher end
but not over that about 50 grams
per day because it is true that
carbohydrates do stimulate insulin and
insulin is an anabolic hormone
however we don't want to go too high
because we're trying to prevent insulin
resistance
so if we provide the the top limit of
carbs i think that would be a smart
thing to do
and of course we want to make sure that
we have enough
complete protein for the muscles to
choose from but not go
too much so seven to eight ounces of
protein per meal
would be a really good option what you
have to realize
is that when you consume protein whether
it's meat
fish or eggs or whatever minimally at
least half of that
is wasted as glucose fuel because it
protein turns in the glucose or as uh
nitrogen waste
so you're not really absorbing 100 of
that unless you're taking
certain types of amino acid blends so by
adding a ton of protein with your meals
that will not help you with this it just
creates more stress on your kidney
and your liver and it can actually
increase your glucose a little bit too
much
and of course sufficient sleep is very
very important because if you're not
sleeping you increase the stress
and the hormone cortisol breaks down
muscle protein now this data that i'm
going to tell you about right now
is very very powerful and i got this
from an
interview from dorian yates so he
actually achieved mr olympia
six times so i wanted to see what he had
to say about
muscle growth and i really liked his
data now it is true
that most bodybuilders including him
took
a lot of steroids and growth hormones
however i really um liked his philosophy
on muscle growth and i think it makes a
lot of sense
personally i am not doing it simply
because that's not my goal
right now but i think um it's worth
looking at
this is what he said now he'll start off
with some warm-up sets
okay some light weight just like most
people will do that so you warm up the
muscle with some lighter weights
but then he will do one insanely
extremely difficult set of about six to
eight
reps so he will do these reps
to total failure and beyond okay
so he will go as hard as he can and then
we can't go anymore
he'll get someone to spot him and assist
him with a few
more reps okay so he's going beyond
total failure
and that's based on this principle of
intensity right here
i mean he is maximizing that
workout intensity because really what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
damage the muscle you're trying to
destroy that muscle
through difficulty now a couple key
points to this
you want to keep perfect form
okay and you don't want to recruit other
muscles
and you don't want to create momentum as
you're working out you're trying to
isolate one muscle
at a time to maximum failure
and beyond but there's something else
that he said that is really really cool
when you uh work a muscle you're gonna
let's say you're doing bench press
you're gonna contract the pec
okay so you're coming out like this and
then you're gonna come back
right so you have concentric movement
which is contraction
then you have eccentric movement which
is lengthening
so if i'm coming down on a bench press
my pecs are lengthening
and the eccentric part which is the
negative part
is actually stronger than the concentric
part but it's often neglected
so what he does with help
he will also then focus on the negative
part
and bring that to failure so if you were
to have someone spot you in a bench
press
and you've just did eight reps to total
failure
you would have them assist you on the
concentric part
okay help you lift it all the way up and
then you would just bring it down
slowly okay and you would keep doing
that
until you can't do it anymore to failure
that way you completely and utterly
exhaust that muscle
to the point where you create some
serious damage now he's only going to
work that muscle
once a week he's not going to hit it
tomorrow the next day
so he works at one muscle per week
and here's the key you let it recover
fully 100 here's a big mistake that a
lot
of people do is they work out
when that muscle is incomplete but
hasn't healed
so that's when you create scar tissue
and injury
so this number five
allowing your muscle to recover fully is
what
makes the muscle get bigger okay
the exercise the intensity is just the
damage of the muscle and then you let it
heal
and so then the next time you work out
you're a little bit stronger
and at some point you want to keep
increasing the weight more and more and
more
until the muscle grows so you don't want
to
go for momentum you want controlled
isolated movement with a pause so if
you're doing a bench press you come all
the way to the end
you pause and then come all the way back
and you come back
on the eccentric part slower than this
part right
here so we have some warm-ups one
intense
set per exercise now he may hit that
muscle like the pec
with maybe three to four to five
different exercises
but he's only going to do that one
intense to total
failure and beyond uh once per
week and for details and all this
definitely get one of his books and you
can read up on it
he works out one hour per day
only four times a week on the off days
he did
cardio which actually helps the recovery
now of course if you're going to do this
you do not want to jump into this right
away because you can hurt yourself you
want to
go into this very very gradual probably
hire a personal trainer to help you
and you want to over a period of weeks
build up to this intense
total failure and beyond a set but i
really think if you combine this
with your keto intermittent fasting keep
your stress low
good sleep you're going to be able to
get muscle hypertrophy
all right and number five very important
okay this is going to get you
this right here so you have to work out
intensely to create the damage in the
soreness
and then you have to recover completely
for you to be able to have this
occur so it might take longer than a
week
it could take two weeks and sometimes
maybe even three if you're just starting
out
thanks for watching before you go if you
have a question about a product
or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call and get some help